what's up gamers welcome back to man of
midnight this is an epic journey so far
you already know if you watch alright
alright so I don't need to speak because
I can't anyway let's go alright it's
getting real now this is where people
die and I don't want to mess up matter
tree pose is to be born by this link
come on come on Juliette I do all the I
do all the moves yeah
it's fine if they died but at least
someone that's not myself cuz we jump
dumb
jump Sheila can jump she's a good jumper
go Julia you're idiot aah
get off
now
Bob guys
[Music]
ah don't you
they said the life now it can still be
line
I like how I just went against
everything I said
are you kidding me are you freaking
kidding me
how am I so dumb I'm like a
self-fulfilling prophecy of dumbness
[Music]
nice-sounding
but he could still be like they could
sell their labs
I'm not buying it sub crying tip-top hey
I know how you're feeling right now I'm
not exactly but
we need to focus on getting out of here
first you know before we think about
anything else okay it's too much I can't
have it me neither that's why we need to
help each other okay we're stronger
together right
least that way we'll have a chance
to be honest he was the character I like
the least so you know I think he was
supposed to die I think he was supposed
to die I'm gonna go ahead and let me say
it he's probably supposed to die oh god
he's gonna scold me no oh hello it's
like than reading the comments seems
appear to have taken a turn towards the
spiritual wouldn't you say I suppose yes
yes now you're one down yeah I know and
poor Alex that really wasn't pretty
was it I've seen worse have you figured
out what's going on how to stop it now
how to save the lives of your poor
unfortunate to stowaways nope you will I
hope Oh although it seems the ship's
previous occupants never managed to
quite a lot of deaths that night let me
help you out
yeah you a little hint thank you not
again what a gap and it smell bring it
well then how can I put this
the maybe forces at play here that a
more scientific and even some that a
more political you know less
supernatural those drugs really it's
drug-related perhaps you've started to
realize something that I have really
nice nipples that everything and
everyone may not be quite what they
appear to be what does this mean I hope
that helps
well aren't you excited to find out what
your poor unfortunates are making of all
this and how you might avoid any more
unnecessary tragedy go on back to it
speak soon ciao ciao I'm sorry for
letting Alex die I am so sorry I don't
know how this happened I wanted him to
live and I freaked that hell is wrong
with you back there
I don't trust please Brad you lost your
[ __ ] like big time you almost killed me
what it must be cursed it's the only way
we can explain all this evil [ __ ] that's
happening down there or drugs come on
I'm the only one that gets to
hyperbolized around here there's got to
be another explanation right this stuff
I saw it's like there were these old
soldiers that there were bodies they
were dead but then they came alive and I
saw something this uh old lady I mean
she was batshit crazy like dinosaur old
not that that's a bad thing but she just
like up and vanished on me Alex wasn't
the only Alex there were things walking
around with his face on them Alex's face
it was horrifying
let's time up okay this place is too
freaky freak back here I'm saying yeah I
mean like something is going on here so
what do we know for sure but we can all
agree on nothing
I look over nothing we're wasting time
whatever we do we have to do it now
pretty sure we can hop back onto the
dupe from here flah said we need the
distributor cap everyone knows if you go
for the gold which I Aradia
god Conrad the Dukes radio got smashed
up in the storm
please just stop joking around I hear
you okay but I'm thinking that tower
means there must be another radio around
here right yeah good chance we could use
the power that keeps coming on - there's
got to be a way up there looks not that
bad right
don't answer that ten I wasn't saying
anything
there's got to be some way off this
bucket of bones am I gonna miss
explosion I think we're speaking
clinically totally tricked got here
somebody shiny something nice listen
Alex were supposed to die I talked to
the developers they just called me
shotgun
I wonder if this ship has anything to do
with the plane from the dive Oh shiny
grab it grab it now
all useless let's keep looking dad I
bought one of those paddle boards you
find a way out if I was on this ship
just give me the paddle board and I'll
be paddling away from here I'll keep my
eyes open
oh we're playing as him
all right what do we got instructions
yes do not panic
attach the gas remember the hammer to
trap gas check the leaks okay whole ship
is just one big box in this box of nuts
that's having I'm trying to turn it but
it doesn't go further oh man I said
there's gas masks
that would the theory about the gas
causing things would add up because once
he left outside he stopped seeing stuff
the talk became untucked you know what I
mean hey help me out over here
you know what I mean something like
don't lie to me all right I know Alex
time ain't exactly the Grand Concourse
but it'll do you want to give me a leg
up but in reality what does Alex done
for anyone mmm
fate hopefully up
so maybe there's a more gas in the car
going that's why I've only fears
tomorrow so I didn't realize which
character I am oh I am him yeah Brad was
moving so awkwardly I was like what is
that mean wait who's that who's that
this is where does that well this is
where she's gone right before
I thought it looked familiar what is
that
did you guys see that oh it's Julia
Julia shame on you it should have been
Julia I think we're that's something we
at least can agree come over here we
might be able to get through this Oh God
[Music]
I'm good at clicking as you can tell
specialty
Julia baby pool if only path Oh Sam good
at rhymes Juliet you make me wanna cool
yeah
hey guy
nice pants bread I had a feeling this
game is just like minecraft it is
realized good
well I bet it was gonna happen can't
voyage so far none of the premonitions
that come true by the way hey look us up
at the Radio Free yeah and everything
else works after sixty years forty years
planned route actual around epic
something's wrong here if you were
headed to San Francisco you'd be crazy
to take this route maybe he they were
layin low
like I didn't seek out in the ocean yes
just like hide-and-seek in the ocean
of course bad cloud cover I guess they
couldn't figure out where they ended up
I'm here radio do you guys hear that oh
man hey look holy moly this radio is
still ticking though radio science
hasn't changed much in seven years as
long as there's power I got this vote
but our pagane military boundary right
hello hello
check check check anybody
[ __ ] yeah man okay
hey hey if you can hear me we're on the
May Day May the huge [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] our coordinates are at 12 degrees
30 minutes south 151 degrees 20 minutes
west May Day May Harry hey [ __ ] okay
we're on this it's an old freighter it's
like huge and abandoned hello can
anybody hear me is there anybody out
there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] can you hear
me
come on [ __ ]
Hey look they're gonna come they're
gonna come they got singing this is a
classic classic horror
sorry this has got to lead somewhere
she's smart we can't find a way to get
the power back if the powers back we
could send a message over the radio I
think someone should wait here in case a
message comes through I gotta be honest
I don't think I'm gonna make it down
there at my shaver [ __ ] it
I'll go Brad mommy man I'm still the
captain of something and the captain is
telling you that I'm going too
all right bliss place stop it you're
embarrassing yourself my place more like
oh please finna die listen at that all
characters are alive I feel really good
about that no you guys okay down there
keep it down up so what's next I don't
know where the hell we keep it down
after making the loudest noise I'll wait
up here by the radio I like this
splitting up always a good plan
everyone knows it this way does oil not
dry up I'm sorry for being too picky
sick where am i controlling right or
hurt right
Sardu sickbay
it's not you all right what do we got no
way
that's not more paper what does this one
say some sort of altercation no wait
that's not what I claimed
[Music]
there was one of them here money
however certain agency was investing it
in chemical biological agents warfare
okay so they were experimenting with new
weapons biological weaponry really you
seem pretty sure to me thanks if by
sharp you mean unsharp yeah I'm sure I'm
big brain big brain gang here come check
this out look down there no way looks
like the engine it's got to be with the
generators you're right let's go down
there
the lighters broken off here if I don't
make it back in a lab I think I can just
hey are you okay yeah oh good
just come down
[Music]
all right did you see it
see what okay okay um okay so hot so I'm
seeing things but you're not I think it
might be from that fog okay yeah you
might be onto something that fog he's
[ __ ] with our heads may rings would
happen here in the first place
my there's nobody left on the ship could
this have anything to do with the
wrecked plane from the dive maybe there
was a connection maybe they make contact
it's a theory I guess well okay let's
keep going a game theory
where we go fun Linden Netherland ah
they make best engine the net the Dutch
know how to make engine like crazy fun
Linden
he was Picasso of engine what do you
think these guys are all about this is
sure yeah money feel like but just ain't
over their heads or something will make
you think they're fishermen fishermen
usually don't have gone do they
okay I hear stuff tickin I hear stuff
took it I don't know about you but I'm
looking
no way look at this the rebreather why
norsu thank the fisherman was sputtered
over from the Duke of Milan you think it
still works no looks like it's got a
little juice left maybe a couple of
minutes should we bring it with us I
mean it's heavy not forget it it's too
heavy to drag along with us you crazy
half the ship is submerged could be a
lifesaver
yeah no stop please a motel
temptation to man Judy deported wha -
Latoya to Silicon Alley
but a fantastic gentle man a good a good
one
famouser I like other stuff that'll
spoil them
good meeting we need that for the poem
this gas in the vent
he's gonna accidentally anus
[Music]
that was a little trickier
yes
why would he do this the gas remember
very careful describe this chippy or is
it
wait don't breathe it I think you might
be wise to steer clear of it yeah yeah
yes
[Music]
are you
what was that
dropping woman alright this is it I'm
not gonna mess up
not a single
there's no use hiding you little foot
height what's the problem with sharing
all that cool there must be many to go
around together yeah
[Music]
[Music]
this guy's like crazy unpredictable we
better get the hell away right freaking
now she took it
[Music]
[Music]
that's gonna hold right definitely
probably probably changing on me now
you think I that's gonna die okay all
right no changing little bit okay raise
your hands up floor I can't do that I
got to be ready for QuickTime event look
like that I said for treating but you
said listen listen to be no fighters you
all just want to get out of here safely
you understand I'm sorry but if you're
breathing and you don't know about the
choice in the matter
you thought could they say
again changing on me what you got a
flip-flop what's changing you gotta stay
away stay back from the mist
dude what mist leave it
don't break the mist why can't we beat
the mystic what does it do its life
bringing things to life that shouldn't
be alive ah stop stop one of us put the
gun down now
okay all right look you got a trailer
once you have something back there maybe
a mist or fog maybe
did you really do now
no look we held our breath we did not
breathe any of that stuff
I know you're all fancy divers but you
expect me to buy that we've been down
here for hours
you've been holding your breath small
time yeah closing a bridge right now
yeah look we have this go bag woman hold
on we have a rebreather yes my boat so
he paid us to have that no way using it
oh my god we could use it on you too you
keep that thing away from me all day
it's amazing
inside
no no I can't see it you're on the right
man
there's believed stop stop stop lying
oh come on ya know just like the mist is
inside
[Music]
hey man come on just put this yeah I
don't want to tell engineer but if we
knew he was gonna do it so at the same
time I don't know what do something that
messes it up I don't care if he lives
he's not the main characters okay that's
really cool about the brief reader so
the fact that we picked to keep it
probably saved one of the cares of life
and at the QuickTime event it was you
had to produce W at one point and he
probably would have taken it from us
that point so there was many put you
know I didn't mess up its basically what
I'm saying that was awesome that was
really awesome I feel good man I don't
like that guy I don't think we need to
repeat that anymore unless we need it
for the gas of course but then one of
the characters going to use it
I'm not [ __ ] John freaking no way
well we have the thing
there's 472 rivets in this room which
can only mean one thing I've been in
here way too long
hey is anyone hurt down there I gotta go
after don't we gotta go make sure
everyone's okay Jesus did something go
wrong
your smile lay here with the radio I'll
go after them seriously Kearney you're
not gonna be able to talk your way
around a maniac with a gun I'm a big boy
this is my mess and I'll clean it up
watch yourself down there I'll make the
call as soon as the radio comes back on
so you better hurry the [ __ ] back Frick
back Frick back don't listen to these
people do not listen good that's a nice
hey can you record that line again yeah
a little bit Morton yeah in it how about
this yeah no no no no no that's not it
we need a little bit of mic yeah yeah I
like this split up that's epic
drop down
always never no fear
we're doing all right Alex Alex Malick's
and I'm saying
stop you guys scared too didn't you
hello it's the beds yes
creeper that door was probably locked
then then one day and clicked on I just
wanted to shake it first premonition
excellent
is that like Leviathan is that like a
biblical thing
what the hell were they
[Music]
maybe the guy that shot himself could
help us later
if we can Vincent I'm just like maybe we
should have tried to save it best we're
done with talks we don't need how the
hell big is this place
ha oh god breathing gasps French people
man like calm down right
they found it all right you can have the
gold front I just want this makeup you
can't just kill my friend and call it
quits your piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah I
thought we were getting like five
oh you think that's the best solution
here
grabbed it out of his hand
[Music]
and run
or as a septic tank
Hey
yes
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but
[Music]
my guess
oh I had to tap it
[Music]
[Music]
I had to tag that I didn't see that at
all
goddammit
[Music]
god dammit a pace
you had to tap it
they did not give you enough time for
that they wanted him to die on the first
plane through come on dude oh that
pisses me off so much I let you down
boys
I'll let you down I don't know what's
the same I hope you guys had fun
watching anyway
excited to come back to play some more
mining my down and finish his series for
you guys we're gonna do it everyone's
gonna live it's gonna be awesome so
epically smash like subscribe and smile
all around March epic well you haven't
tried to pursue malade at City after 50
million outros much go just go it's
still relevant just down a bit